she's Amy Trask and hi hi Amy how you
doing well I'm doing well is it odd that
after all these years of having worked
with you on League matters just being a
fan of yours that I'm still kind of
nervous joining you on your head come on
how could you be nervous of being on
this show and you've walked into any
sorts of meetings with Al Davis over the
years that never made you nervous not
once you know it didn't I'm a Jew born
in Brooklyn too and other than that I
think that's the end of me and Al Davis
having any sort of connection to each
other I don't know we both love football
okay first order of business what do you
make of levy on Bell's business strategy
this year Amy you know it's tough to say
for the following reason we don't know
what he was advised we don't know if he
was advised in one manner but chose to
not take that advice and certainly it is
absolutely his right to proceed in any
manner he believes best for himself so
while I have concerns about the decision
he made from strictly a financial
standpoint and the ability to recoup
money the ability to recoup a year of
his life so to speak not in a literal
sense I don't question the decision of
someone else to do what he believes was
the right thing and in his best interest
irrespective of whether I do or I jump
no I know I I hear you it seems though
that he just he had a point that he
wanted to make that his value was not
what the Steelers were valuing and he
was not going to show up and and then
maybe he thought he needed to and then
he found out that he didn't I'm curious
to know if that was part of it but I
understand him not showing up now right
I mean he's got a he's got a payday
where he needs to make 14 million more
than he was going to essentially right
and enrich you know as well as anyone
that every player he
is one play away from a catastrophic
injury a career ending industry injury
and and when I say catastrophic I really
do mean that not simply in a career
standpoint we had a running back who had
a life-threatening injury that not only
ended his career but could have been far
worse so you know if he made this
decision for strategic reasons I will
not question him because it is his life
in his decision to make but I did have
the sense that there was some amount of
confusion with respect to this with an
understanding of the rules again I don't
know what his agent was advising him it
also strikes me as somewhat sad I I just
wonder if he was happy with his decision
or if this snow balled a me Trask ear on
the Rich Eisen show so how do you think
management types in the NFL general
managers owners team presidents will
approach levy on Bell's impending free
agency with him being out a year and
also with his suspension history and I
don't bring that up to denigrate at all
but that is what is always going to be
put in there because those don't go away
those accumulate and and potentially
manifest themselves in a longer
suspension next time out how do you
think he will what type of contract do
you think is going to be put in front of
him
well it'll be organizational specific as
you know the points you made are not
only a hundred percent accurate but so
important there will be teams whether
it's ownership or management that look
at the points you just noted and be wary
in proceeding either because of the
suspensions or because of the manner in
which he handled this things this year
and there will be plenty of other
organizations who simply say can this
man help us win and as you know rich the
owner for whom I worked often didn't
look at anything other than whether or
not he believed it could help us on the
field and while that is absolutely
commendable in some instances there were
other instances in which I
he should have factored more into the
analysis this isn't one of those though
or I should say the suspension issue is
something to look at
I wouldn't let what he did this year
impact my decision at all huh none you
know I really wouldn't and I guess I
should put one footnote on that I would
have to have a conversation with him
about it and I would have to understand
what happened was this calculated does
he feel that he was well advised did it
snowball I would want to understand what
went into the decision but the point you
made as to the sort of cumulative nature
of suspensions and and punishment that's
a real concern so do you think he's I
guess then final one on this one do you
think he's going to get that four
five-year long-term contract with all
sorts of back-end numbers that he feels
the year off will allow him to reach
because he has lack of tire tread on him
do you think he's going to get that
based on everything that we have seen
play out right now any trend not perhaps
not to the extent he believes she can
now a team can do something to help him
save face if you will and they can
announce a contract that just sounds you
know she's a very technical business
time humongous but as you know if it's
back-ended and if there are no
guarantees it can sound very large but
ultimately when you read the language of
the contract you realize it is simply a
year-to-year contract will he get a good
amount I do believe so will it be as big
as he wishes it to be that's harder to
imagine okay so what's more confusing do
you think in your mind Amy Trask to
figure out if there was a plan or is
there a plan or what the plan is
levy on bail or Jon Gruden Amy Trask
Wow that puts a girl on the spot right
look I I will caveat this by sounding
fight by stating that I shall forever
and always wish nothing but success for
Raider fans and the Raider Nation and so
I
say what I'm about to say with that in
mind because I want success for them and
rich I was really hopeful that in the
year or possibly two years the team has
remaining before fleeing Oakland that
they would deliver for the fans in that
region that said I will cut to the chase
and say that I'm very perplexed by what
is going on when the owner hired Reggie
six years ago the mandate if you will
was I think the language was deconstruct
and then reconstruct John has come in
and clearly he or the owner or both of
them have decided that that
reconstruction was not a success and
they are again beginning a rebuild well
fair enough that's John's right to do as
the new person with total control of the
the operations of the team but if you're
going to rebuild again fair enough I
don't understand the manner in which
it's being done spending close to sixty
million dollars on aging veterans who
aren't going to be there for a long-term
rebuild I don't begrudge the signing of
veterans they can help a team but why
wouldn't you have taken that money and
allocated it to the person I believe was
Reggie Mackenzie's best draft picked by
a wide margin which is Khalil max that
is precisely the type of player you
should build around so I get it John was
not impressed with the rebuild that was
done he wants to do his own rebuild fair
enough he's got the authority to do so
but I don't understand the manner in
which it's being done and and by the way
giving away some draft kicks for
veterans as well as all that money I
would have thought that the team would
have wanted to build a round Kaleo max
your best guess you think Derrick cars
on that roster starting 2019 ami Trask
if you were to sort of put the
proverbial gun to my head
I would say yes but I'm giving it just
slightly over a 50% yes I I don't think
it's assured by any stretch and the
question is of course are they able to
draft
when they think better remember they
just gave derrick karr a very very big
contract and yes they can walk away it
not a substantial cost but they have to
believe they can do better in the draft
or otherwise if they're to let him go
so what would I'll make of this if he
was alive today seeing what's going on
Gruden back his son giving them nine
more years on a 10-year contract the
deconstruction you say I think they're
tanking Amy I think they're tanking I
think that they got that the Bruce Irvin
cut is the latest example of underneath
the patina if you will or veil of not
this team's type of player cutting a
pass rusher when you have been lamenting
your lack of pass rush as they have and
I don't know what was going on in the
locker room I think they've tanking and
I think it's better than 50/50 coin flip
that the Commissioner gets a tanking
question put in front of him at this
year's Super Bowl State of the Union
address because it is so blatant in my
thought so what do you think I would say
on the subject well interesting point
about a question to Roger Goodell I had
not considered that that's interesting I
think it's common I mean how else to
take this fascinating to me Rich's even
assume for the moment that you're
correct
which of course I always I've never seen
an athlete take the field with any
intent other than to win that's yeah
that's harder than others so even if
what you're positing is corrected it's
really incomprehensible to me to imagine
that there's buy-in of that or
participation in that on the player
level but that doesn't mean you know
you're not right in other regards you
know I would have done something
entirely differently and by the way he
would have been heavily criticized for
it and by the way he wouldn't have cared
about the criticism he would have found
a way to keep Khalil and Mac and he
would and when I say he would have done
it in a manner that would have generated
criticism outlook enriched if I had the
proverbial dollar for every time al said
to me during my career the
order back must go down and he must go
down hard yeah I could probably buy a
team and she says facetiously he would
he cherished pass rush and he would have
found a way to keep Cleo Mac and you
know what he would have overpaid or he
would have paid an amount that many in
the league would have deemed overpayment
and he wouldn't have given adawn because
he would have found a way to get it to
get his guy so I do think he would have
disagreed with the approach to Khalil
Mac and he would have done what people
called overpaying and he wouldn't care
well I'm glad you said when you said is
well Amy because I do want to say that I
do not believe Raiders players are
putting on a helmet and pads and cleats
every week with the intention of losing
a football game I don't think that at
all and I don't think Jon Gruden is
putting on a headset with the intention
of we are losing today what I'm saying
is that when you cut so much meat off
the bone and put it on the field you
know you're not going to be ultra
competitive when it's all said and done
and that you know that potentially human
nature takes over and tents get folded
up second third quarter as opposed to
maybe fourth or not at all that's why I
got you thank you for helping you know I
was always the kid the slow kid in the
back of the car no no no but you make a
great point that I don't think that
players go on the field or coaches go
out there the intent to losing but
before I let you go what what do you
think happened in in the front office is
what do you know if anything to happen
in 345 Park Avenue for their league to
pull up stakes on the Mexico game that
you know they wanted to play with with
every intention you know what credit to
the National Football League the
National Football League did the right
thing
it prioritized player safety over
business interests as you just noted
rich the league wanted that game in
Mexico and it did the right thing and
you know I tweeted out yesterday early
early in the morning if that field is
not safe the game should be moved and
there are all tremendous tremendous
amount of logistics associated with it
costs associated with it I do believe
the league should do all it can to make
the fans who purchased tickets to that
game in Mexico hole for the ticket price
and perhaps a travel stipend for future
travel but at the end of the day the
league did the right thing you cannot
talk about prioritizing player safety if
you don't prioritize player safety and I
say hats off to the NFL because it did
that so do you did you hear that players
are planning on boycotting I I did hear
some chitter chatter about that and
irrespective whether of whether it was
going to be an actual boycott was simply
an articulation of concerns to the
extent the league factored in how
strongly the players felt again credit
to the league I think the league did the
right thing it is not an easy business
decision it's going to be costly I do
want the fans taken care of and I hope
we can use this moment in Los Angeles to
do something for the community with
respect to the fires and the shootings
at that game but the league did the
right thing do you think that the fact
that there were two Super Bowl
contenders playing in this game led to
any of it you know call me an optimist
some people might say in your being
Pollyanna about this I will I believe
and I want to believe and I hope to
believe the league would have done the
same irrespective of the teams all right
Amy thanks for the time really really
love it gotta get you in here in person
next time but you know I would love to
and thank you for having me every time
every time amy Trask's there's really
nobody quite like her the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience